avec
[Musique]
plaisir j'ai planté un chêne au bout de
mon champ ce fut ma semaine perdrerai-je
ma peine j'ai planté un chêne au bout de
mon champ perderai-je ma peine
perderai-je mon
temps
l'amour et la haine ce sont mes enfants
et ce sont mes chaînes perderai-je ma
peine l'amour et la haine ce sont mes
enfants perderai-je ma peine perderai-je
mon
temps le roi et la reine perdront leur
manant mais l'amour m'enchaîne
perdreraije ma peine le roi et la reine
perdrant leur manant perderai-je ma
peine perdrerai-je mon
[Musique]
temps serit capitaine sur mon bâtiment
tout en bois de chîne perderai-je ma
peine serai capitaine sur mon bâtiment
perdrerai-je ma peine perdrerai-je mon
temps
j'ai planté un chîn au bout de mon champ
ce fut ma semaine perdreraije ma peine
j'ai planté un chne au bout de mon champ
perdrerje ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peine
perderaije mon
temps
[Musique]
foreign